welcome to the david pakman show i am
farron cousins from ring of fire here
with you once again we've got a
phenomenal show coming up today
obviously we've got to talk about
trump's lawsuit against the doj
and the revelation that there were 700
pages of classified documents retrieved
so far this year from mar-a-lago we've
got two of the individuals
who
were plotting to kidnap
governor gretchen whitmer from michigan
they have been convicted we've got don
jr excusing his father's actions we've
got alex jones walking back his
endorsement of ron desantis all kinds of
things
coming up on today's show so
let's jump right in obviously
one of the bigger things that happened
early this week
is the fact that donald trump
not only filed a lawsuit against the doj
seeking a special master to go through
the documents make sure there's nothing
privileged in there
but also in the filing
it appears that his lawyers actually
admitted
that he did the things that of course he
is being accused of
right here twice in the document
meaning the you know lawsuit and the
other documents that have come to light
trump admits he took government
documents which is illegal under the
espionage act and the presidential
records act
huh
you know i'm not a lawyer i work with
lawyers i i
am the editor of a legal magazine but i
gotta tell you usually when lawyers file
motions
they don't admit
to the crimes that their clients have
been accused of and
yet right there clear as day
there's two separate times where his
lawyers admit yes
um we had the documents
uh the fbi at one point told us to
secure them a little bit better so
donald trump said put a second lock on
the door
that that's in the document
and then of course they admitted it
again when they said if the fbi you know
all they had to do was come ask we would
have
you know given them the things that they
were after so you're admitting you did
it
and we know from last week of course
that reports came out saying donald
trump is unable
to attract decent lawyers
one because they don't want to tie their
name to it because they know how
unpredictable trump is and if he does
something stupid the lawyer gets blamed
for it they don't want to be a part of
that and also they're afraid they're
never going to get paid if they do legal
work for him so donald trump of course
is left with what i like to call the
bottom of the barrel
not you know what that's not even fair
to barrels okay these are not lawyers
from the bottom of the barrel he had to
tip the barrel over
and dig down a couple of feet
to find legal minds
horrible enough
to admit in their own filings
that yeah i mean he did it
but is it always bad if he does it is is
it always a crime
but all that aside the lawsuit itself uh
depending on who you ask
is either going to succeed or fail and i
know that's a very weird thing to say
but again it depends on which legal
expert you're talking to you're reading
or you're seeing you know their massive
threads on twitter explaining this
because everybody seems to have a
different thought
on what is happening here
a lot of them say that this lawsuit well
pretty much all of them say the lawsuit
is just an effort to stall right that's
a given we understand that he's stalling
the real question becomes whether or not
the lawsuit itself can be successful
that's where the divide happens
because some legal experts and i'm
talking about all the people these are
all people on the left
some say
it's an absolute farce and it has no
chance of being successful because
the special master would be appointed if
they believed some of the retrieved
materials
700 pages of classified documents
were privileged
and that is where another dichotomy
breaks down so
if it's attorney-client privilege
then a special master would in this
particular instance be warranted under
most circumstances
not necessarily all
right if they're documents that trump
and his lawyer are discussing committing
crimes together
outside of what he's being represented
for then no that would not fall under
attorney-client privilege
if it is donald trump communicating with
his lawyer about legal actions things
like that that is privileged you can't
have those
the other kind of privilege
is executive privilege
which of course we have heard donald
trump say some of these things are
executive privilege
and
that's not going to fly you're not going
to get a special master because you say
these things are covered under executive
privilege
there's one person on the planet
who has the authority
to determine whether or not something is
covered under executive privilege that
person right now
is president joe biden
so if biden were to come out and say
none of these are executive privilege
then guess what
none of them are executive privilege
if he doesn't do that and trump did
claim privilege over some of them they
would still have that executive
privilege distinction until
the next person in line whoever that
president will be if it's biden now or
anybody else down the road takes it away
that's how the executive privilege works
once it's there it is there and it can
transfer from administration to
administration
but once you leave office it's out of
your control
so if the next person in line says no
it's not covered then it's not covered
and then of course you would not get a
special master
having said all of that
let me say this because again depending
on what kind of privilege it may or may
not take effect depending on what's in
the privileged it may or may not take
effect
any of that i don't care
i'm in favor of the special master
and there's one very specific and i feel
it's a good reason
for everybody to say you know what we'll
do the special master thing
give trump what he wants right
now because he's making a big deal of
this
so if he gets that special master
all of his followers are going to look
at it and say okay good we have
oversight
and then if you find the crimes
you know if well the having the
documents themselves was the crime um if
you find it is what you think it is and
you can indict him
having that special master there
it's not going to convince trump he'll
then attack the special master it's not
going to convince the maga hat wearing
crowd that everything was legitimate but
what it will do is it will convince all
of those republicans who are right now
on the fence they don't know whether or
not to support what's happening or to be
against it
those are the people that are going to
say well
there was a special master
they had the oversight trump they gave
trump what he wanted
and it still came to that conclusion
so i guess this was real
i guess this was legitimate
i'm not even saying folks that you're
going to have a large number of people
who who do that
but even if you have a handful of them
that's more than you've got right now
so why not just do it yeah is it going
to slow things down a little bit sure
but if you go ahead and agree and give
in to the demands of this lawsuit which
i am typically against giving in to any
demands of these right-wingers
but if you do it now you're going to
avoid a lengthy court process where
nothing's going to be able to happen in
the interim
so agree to it today get the special
master then start going through the
documents you save yourself a lot of
time that way trump doesn't get to stall
it but for more than what a week
and he gets what he wants
and some folks out there might view this
a little bit more legitimately than they
already were
that's why i think the special master
is a good idea i do think it's something
that the doj
needs to entertain
it's not obviously out of the realm of
possibility
it happens all the time in criminal
investigations just do it
give this thing even more legitimacy
is what i say
take away one of donald trump's biggest
talking points he'll still use it
but it's not going to be as effective
against as many people
if you just do do what he wants right
now
and reap the benefits later
but the doj may have other things that
they have in mind as well because
according to reports out this week the
doj is also seeking
more
surveillance footage
from mar-a-lago
now as we all know the doj already has
their hands on some of the surveillance
footage from mar-a-lago
and in fact it was getting that
surveillance footage
that kind of expedited the need for the
fbi to go down there and seize all these
documents to begin with
and now reports say the doj needs even
more they want more
and that can only mean one thing
according to the experts
that one thing of course
is that they didn't get it all that
there could be more
documents
hiding down there in mar-a-lago or maybe
maybe they were loaded up and taken
somewhere else
so that when the fbi showed up
some of the even worse stuff that trump
may have stolen
wasn't even on site and they didn't know
that he had moved it that's why they
want
that surveillance footage
at least that's the prevailing theory
honestly makes a heck of a lot of sense
these doj investigators are not doing
this willy-nilly right they're not
flying by the seat of their pants
they're making sure that they have
crossed their t's that they have dotted
their eyes
and that they have the evidence to back
up any claim or request that they make
because they understand
the political ramifications of going
after a former president
especially one with a cult following
like donald trump
especially one whose followers are out
there right now making death threats
against the very people doing these
investigations
and they're looking at all that and
they're looking at their evidence and
they're saying you know what
we need more
so for them to even think that right now
tells me they have what they believe i
think is pretty strong evidence
that they don't have all of the evidence
and that's a terrifying thought in and
of itself right trump could be hiding
even more
documents there could there could be
more than just the 700 pages of
classified information
some of it again pertaining to nuclear
documents
i i'd say that's a worth a look through
the footage right
i think that's something maybe we want
to be looking into
it remains to be seen of course they
have not officially
made the request for that extra
surveillance footage it could be coming
any day now
we have to wait and see and that that
honestly is is always the hardest part
right
especially with donald trump
we have to be patient
just like we have to be patient with the
january 6 hearings we have to be patient
with the
new york investigations and then the
georgia investigation and
the lawsuits about him possibly inciting
the riot causing the injuries to the
police officers and the eg carroll
defamation lawsuit which honestly still
to me in my opinion is the biggest one
out there
because of what it could prove about
donald trump if he ever gives that dna
sample so there's a lot of things
which means we got to have a lot of
patience
and that's not always easy
but that's the position that we are in
right now
i am farron cousins for more from me by
the way you can follow me on youtube at
youtube.com
the ring of fire you can also follow my
other youtube channel youtube.com
farron balanced and i'm on twitter
facebook and instagram at
farren
balanced this is the david pakman show
i'm farron cousins in for david pakman
and we'll be right back with more
one of our sponsors today is ketoned we
all have heard about the ketogenic diet
which puts your body in a metabolic
state of ketosis many have reported that
it's helpful for curbing hunger or even
weight loss ketoned is the top rated
ketone supplement on the market it
allows you to enjoy the benefits without
dramatically restricting your carbs and
if you already follow a ketogenic diet
ketoned is a great way to instantly
boost your ketone levels their formula
works in under 20 minutes take ketoned
advanced blend and then test your ketone
levels and see for yourself comes in
delicious flavors like aloha punch
tiger's blood citrus mango peach and
caramel macchiato or caramel macchiato
or caramel macchiato
ketone has helped millions of people on
their keto journey since 2016. read
online what ketone customers have to say
and ketoned is giving my audience 30 off
plus two free bottles of keto charged
when you go to
ketoned.com pacman and use the code
pacman at checkout
welcome back to the david pakman show i
am farin cousins from ring of fire
sitting in for david pakman once again
today
you know we've already talked a lot
about donald trump the documents
mar-a-lago the investigation and all
that and i don't want to continue
talking about that even though that is
dominating the news making it harder to
find any stories but there's one more
thing
i got to talk about with it and that one
more thing is trump's son donald trump
jr
on monday donald trump jr
came down to my
city of pensacola florida to campaign of
course for republican candidate matt
gates
which gates didn't really need it he was
going to win the primary easily but
junior comes down brings kimberly
guilfoyle with him they do an event and
it was during this event
that junior
started talking about the the
investigation into the documents and all
that stuff stored down there at
mar-a-lago and junior
not only defended his father
but said that if he had you know what
i'm not going to give it away i'm going
to read the quote
this is what donald trump jr said in
pensacola florida on monday
by the way for the record which okay you
don't have to put both of those
qualifiers in there
you would either say by the way or for
the record but you don't need to say by
the way for the record
just
a little grammar lesson there for
everybody
by the way for the record i'd say that
if donald trump actually still had the
nuclear codes it'd probably be good
our enemies might actually be like okay
maybe let's not mess with them unlike
when they look at joe biden and they say
you know what we should attack
now see i was unaware
and maybe it's because of my sleepy
little town but i was unaware that
foreign leaders were actually out there
saying let's go attack america right now
have there been attacks like does it
happen while i'm sleeping and then
nobody tweets about it so i don't see it
the next day
or
or is he just making stuff up because
he's a [ __ ]
i'm gonna go with the latter on that one
by the way um
[Music]
here's the other part of his incredibly
stupid statement
if donald trump still had nuclear codes
in those documents well guess what they
would no longer be valid i i can promise
you they've probably changed the codes
multiple times since donald trump left
office
but even assuming they hadn't right
let's indulge junior's little fantasy
here assuming
they had not changed the nuclear codes
and donald trump did have
them he still couldn't issue a nuclear
strike and the rest of the world knows
that
because he's not
the president of the united states does
junior think that anybody with those
nuclear codes is just able to order
a nuclear strike
i mean i guess if you did a good enough
you know biden impression
and you had the nuclear codes you you
might be able to do something like that
but
just having the codes in and of themself
doesn't give you the authority
to launch nuclear weapons
so again
not 100 sure exactly what junior is
trying to tell us here
but i can tell you that everything he
says is completely false
like one we don't have world leaders
sitting around like oh trump's gone
great let's go fire missiles at america
because apparently what trump took the
entire military with him
is it is it just gone now like we didn't
just give them 800 billion dollars for
the next 12 months
did i make all that up
was that all just a fever dream that i
had
no the military is still there we still
have all the weapons that we had when
trump was there if not more at this
point obviously because we just picked
more up every year
so yeah the rest of the world still
knows that no matter who's in charge of
the white house
we can still do some pretty significant
damage to them if they were to come over
here and attack us
so
no matter which way you slice junior's
little weird fantasy there of trying to
defend his father's behavior
it makes no sense
and trust me i've been trying to make
sense of it for quite some time and dang
it
i simply cannot do it
and speaking of things that also make
absolutely no sense whatsoever
new reports have revealed that ice
officials were instructed by the trump
administration
to wipe their cell phones
before he left office
so prior to january 20th of 2021
we have ice officials it has now been
confirmed of course
that deleted
all of the data off of their phones
just like we saw with members of the
department of justice members of the
department of homeland security and of
course most famously the united states
secret service
everybody just wiped all their phones
deleted everything off it text messages
emails notes games
whatever it was
totally erased it all
and even if
just like the secret service claimed
right oh this was just routine we just
this is a thing we do cool totally
understand that
you're still required by law
to preserve the data
and that's the big part that i think a
lot of people don't quite understand
about this
it is not
routine
for the doj for the homeland security
for the secret service to just wipe
everything off the phone
and turn it back in and say all right
thank you bye i'll see you next time
no
the phones are taken
inventory is done
they are copied
and then
they are wiped
and this of course only applies to
agency issued phones which
most of these people do have agency
issued phones and they have it for that
specific reason so that the data is
saved so that there are records of the
things that they do the communications
that they have
so that they can make sure these
individuals are not sending it to people
who shouldn't be receiving it and in
case there's any malfeasance we can
point it out
due to the records on their devices
and now we know that ice
immigrations and customs enforcement
wiped their phones just like so many
other government agencies
under donald trump
i don't know
how much more of this
we can go through
how many more
cell phones were wiped
before trump left
how many other agencies how many other
officials were given these orders to
scrub it all to get rid of any evidence
get rid of any trace of anything make
sure nobody knows who we were talking to
and when we were talking to them and
what we were talking to them
about
that should terrify you
and every single person involved
needs to be investigated because like i
said it's illegal
to delete these records
they are required by law to back them up
and i'm not saying go find the it
department and arrest those guys
for wiping the devices
they probably didn't know that they
hadn't been backed up
whoever made the call whoever made the
decision
for all of these devices to be wiped at
whatever agency it is we're talking
about that day
those are the people that need to be
held accountable
and
maybe there's a couple honest folks in
there
maybe some of them backed up their own
data maybe they understood that i was
just following orders is not necessarily
a good excuse
for breaking the law so maybe
there are records somewhere right even
in the case of the secret service and
all they're missing cell phone data once
the investigation was lost they came
back and magically said oh wait wait we
just found data on 10 devices look at
that wow suddenly it's crazy
we may be looking at a situation like
that
but only if we put the pressure on these
organizations and that pressure has to
either come from congress or it has to
come from the biden administration via
the department of justice
that's what has to happen
remains to be seen though right
i guess we have to wait
and another thing by the way and i just
thought this was so
just such a such a wonderful story last
week
alex jones
came out
did a video
where he told his audience
that he was officially endorsing
florida governor ron desantis for
president over donald trump
he not only said
that ron desantis was in jones's words
way better than trump way better than
trump his exact words he also said that
desantis is the kind of guy that uh what
trump should be like
again his exact words what trump should
be like
that was last week
now earlier this week alex jones
realized oh no
i've made a mistake and i've made the
big guy angry
even though as far as i've seen donald
trump has not issued any statements
whatsoever
attacking alex jones for that
so i don't buy for a second alex jones
is oh no trump's angry hey he didn't say
anything didn't seem like he cared
but anyway alex jones comes out this
week
in
what's called an emergency warning
and he says this
not a warning out of any desire to hurt
you mr trump but to save your important
legacy and hopefully ensure you can get
back into the white house coming up in
2024. we know the election was stolen we
know the deep state is trying to set you
up in any way they can we understand you
are a lion surrounded by hyenas so this
is my emergency message to you mr
president to go and actually watch the
first 30 minutes of thursday's show so
you can see what i said in context
the corporate media edited it down to a
30-second clip to make it sound like i'm
only for desantis and that i've
abandoned you that's not true it's the
contrary
right
that that that's totally believable
i mean it's not like you just got popped
for 40 million dollars for lying
so yes we totally believe that the clip
we all saw with our own eyes
heard it with our own ears processed it
with our own brains was totally just
fabricated the media made it up
they deceptively edited it
no
you're on video
literally saying ron desantis is way
better than donald trump
this is what trump should be like
you said that you can look into santa's
eyes here it is um
i don't just watch a man's actions as
christ said judge a tree by its fruit i
can also look in his eyes on hd video
and i see the real sincerity
is that taken out of context
with you talking about how much
you just love ron desantis over donald
trump you also said that you're no
longer you know gonna pig-headedly
that's the word you used support donald
trump
but again this little begging for
forgiveness thing for donald trump i
don't buy it because trump didn't say a
word
i don't know that trump was mad about it
i don't know that trump knew it happened
you know we know trump sits and watches
tv all day long but i don't know that
he's sitting there and watching alex
jones
so i think what happened is that jones
realized he made a lot of his trump
supporting audience mad
so that little emergency warning he
issued that wasn't to make donald trump
happy
that was to make jones audience happy by
trying to convince them that what he
said last week
totally never happened
i am fair and cousins in for david
pakman you can get more from me on
youtube at youtube.com
fair and balanced and youtube.com the
ring of fire i'm on twitter facebook and
instagram at fair and balanced this is
the david pakman show i'm farin cousins
in for david pakman and we'll be right
back
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
welcome back to the david pakman show i
am farron cousins from ring of fire
sitting in for david pakman today and
what do you say folks you ready for some
non-donald trump news because i know i
sure am
so let's start with this two individuals
adam fox and barry croft are now facing
a maximum of life in prison after a jury
convicted them this week
in their plot to kidnap
michigan governor
gretchen
whitmer
now this plot i'm sure most people
understand and remember what happened
but just in case you didn't you had
these individuals along with several
other right-wing extremists
that became so angry about governor
whitmer's coveted restrictions
that they began plotting and the fbi
actually had an informant within their
little group a guy called big dan
big dan
is in there in their little extremist
group where they're plotting
to go and kidnap governor whitmer
from her vacation home
and they had their weapons they were
practicing with explosives
and that's also by the way another
charge that they received but they
they were going to do this they were
going to overthrow
the government of the state of michigan
through this kidnapping plot
this is actually the second time
these two men had been on trial the
first one
resulted in a mistrial
because the jury obviously could not
come to any unanimous decision and the
defense
had done a fairly successful job of
arguing at least successful in terms of
the jury being hung there
of convincing them
that the fbi
set up basically
entrapment for these individuals the fbi
guy big dan
let's let's not disrespect big dan by
calling him anything else big dan
um
basically working for the fbi convinced
these men to do it
right if big dan hadn't been there
pulling the little puppet strings they
never would have thought about
kidnapping governor whitmer
but this time around of course the the
jury said no you are not making a
convincing case that
big dan is the guy responsible for this
so
they got convicted again they're facing
life in sentence life in prison excuse
me as their sentence at a maximum
now
here's what drives me insane
about this particular story
these men
wanted to kidnap and most likely kill
a democratically elected governor
because of covid
restrictions
that's what this was over that's what
this is about and yes these individuals
had you know expressed anti-government
sentiment on social media for years
which is one of the reasons that the
jury this time didn't buy the fbi
entrapment argument
but this was the last straw like how
dare you
try to take care of people during a
public health emergency the likes of
which we have never seen in modern
america how dare you
tell us to wear masks how dare you
tell us that we have to socially
distance i'm going to kill you
because you don't want me to die
because let's be honest that's what this
was that's what coveted restrictions
were
and we saw it across the country not
kidnapping plots thank god
but we saw these lunatics burning masks
getting children to throw masks into
burning trash cans
protesting over the fact that we don't
want you to die
but apparently that's a bridge too far
for these freaks
like you you can't
want to take care of them you can't want
to protect them
because if you do
they may try to kill you
okay can you wrap your heads around that
for just a moment folks
that's where we're at that's what we
have come to
and of course we're acting like cove
it's not still out there killing a
couple thousand people a week in this
country which it is
we don't have any restrictions anywhere
anymore you're free to do whatever
but you're assuming the risks
and we still have people out there
trashing vaccines
posting misinformation
ranting and raving about non-existent
coveted protection measures because
again they don't exist anywhere anymore
but they're still mad
they're still protesting
they're still acting like oh my god this
is terrible this is tyranny
all because
some lawmakers not even all of them but
just some of them
actually wanted to protect their
constituents and not
let them die from a deadly disease which
at the time of the kidnapping plot we
had no treatments for we had no vaccines
for
we had no way to protect ourselves other
than wearing the masks and socially
distancing and avoiding unnecessarily
large
gatherings
that's all we could do we didn't have
the paxlavit pills
we didn't have vaccines as i said we had
nothing
we were throwing the spaghetti against
the wall when it came to treatment
that's why so many people died
but i guess that's what these
you know extremists would have preferred
let me die
i'd rather die than have to wear a mask
i'd rather kidnap the governor of a
state
than not be able to go to chile's for
drinks after work on friday
that is unfortunately the country that
we live in today
and of course the misinformation that
was flowing during covet has not slowed
down in fact it has gotten worse
according to a new
report from m booth health a study
called the pharma brandemic
more than 000 demographically diverse
adults across the united states were
polled
and here's what they found the
overwhelming majority of respondents 88
percent have encountered health care
misinformation and nearly three-quarters
73 percent are anxious about it
more than one in three believe they come
across false health information almost
every day
so health misinformation
in case you haven't noticed
is growing out of control
these these alleged crackdowns by social
media outlets and youtube like oh we're
not going to let all this you know
misinformation out there we're finally
taking down the massive anti-vaxx
facebook page that should have been
taken down years ago
that by the way that group the
children's health defense i think they
made what six million dollars last year
i think is what i had read um they make
a lot of money whether it's six million
or not um they do make a lot of money
and
they were removed because facebook
finally said uh we think this is
misinformation
we've got polio in new york
that's what medical misinformation does
a million people dead from covet in this
country
that's what medical misinformation
does
but that's not even the striking part of
this study from in booth health
here's the striking part to me
separately
we also this from the daily beast by the
way
separately we also surveyed 101
full-time health care providers almost
all 99
of them
said they have patients share
misinformation every week and 90 of
medical professionals are anxious about
this
nearly half 48 percent say they now have
less confidence that patients will
comply with their recommendations
perhaps unsurprisingly the same
percentage of patients 48 percent say
they are now more comfortable
challenging their doctor
so all of this misinformation
and there's another part to it other
than just misinformation i'll get to
that in a moment but all of this
misinformation what it's doing right now
according to doctors and health care
workers is you've got people walking
into the doctor's office the doctor says
okay look you have this problem we're
going to do x y and z we're going to get
you fixed up hopefully and we're going
to make you better
and the patient says now hold on there
jack
i may not have gone to medical school
but i saw on facebook right from this uh
this very important group they've got
like 10 million followers
they say you're wrong
they say give me the horse medicine
that's what i want maybe i should have
gone to the vet instead
and the doctors like they can't do
anything about it they can sit there and
say well as somebody that went to
medical school and has been practicing
medicine for a couple decades you're
wrong please do what i'm saying
and then the patient leaves and half the
doctors are like yeah that person's not
going to listen to me
doctors are getting burnt out from this
the report also states
because you know why the burnout happens
because when that patient that doesn't
want to take the doctor's advice because
they know better because they read it on
facebook
they don't listen to the doctor they get
worse they come back
and no matter how many i told you so as
the doctor gives the patient still
insists
no
i'm still right i may be on my deathbed
because i didn't listen to you but darn
it i'm still right
until of course their final moments as
we saw plenty of times during the
pandemic
people on their death bed saying i wish
i'd gotten the shot
i wish i had taken this seriously
i wish i hadn't followed the
misinformation
that's what we're seeing in this country
and as i mentioned there's another part
of it too
it's not just the misinformation
it's the overwhelming amount of
information
and that overwhelming amount of
information i'm talking about is coming
from the drug drug companies themselves
another thing that's happening that's
also frustrating doctors to no end
is the fact that we have direct to
consumer advertising of prescription
drugs here in the united states
and what's been happening for 20 years
now
is that patients go into the doctor's
office
not waiting for the doctor to tell them
what they need but they go in and act
like they're ordering at a deli
they say hey doc yeah i've got these
problems but i saw this commercial on tv
i want that drug i want that thing
the people in the commercial looked all
happy they're dancing i want to dance
give me the drug and if you think i'm
making that up
go and look through all the studies from
the last 20 years that have shown that
people are now walking into the doctor's
office demanding give me this thing i
saw on tv
which is why we're one of only two
countries on the planet new zealand
being the other one that even allows
that to happen in the first place the
direct to consumer advertising that's
where we're at today
we're inundated with news from big
pharma
saying hey you need this drug
all these people in the commercial
taking it they look happy they're fun
you know they're living their lives
don't you want to live your life
and then on the other side you have
people saying
oh no you don't need any of this
what you need is to go out there and eat
a couple of handfuls of dirt
and that'll make it all better
don't don't trust big pharma and so we
are stuck in this in between
i have seen
again through my work for almost 20
years with with various law firms
i've seen the documents from big pharma
these folks are scumbags up and down no
question about it they will lie to your
face about a drug that is going to kill
you and tell you it's the only thing you
ever need to take and you're going to be
great
it is difficult to trust these
individuals
at the same time they do still produce
life-saving medication
so it's easy to see how you get to that
misinformation
there is a lot of distrust there and
there should be
because again a lot of the people
including some of the prominent
anti-vaxxers they fought these companies
in court
but it skewed them to the point where
they now believe you can't trust
anything
the truth is somewhere in between
and unfortunately for doctors
the public doesn't know what to do they
don't know who to trust
we're just kind of left in the middle
big pharma is greedy big pharma rips us
off
big pharma tries to sell us drugs we
don't need
but they also make things we do need
like vaccines
and life-saving medications
that we just wish we could afford to
take
but then all of that greed
all of those horrible documents feeds
into the you can't trust big pharma
they're only out to kill you
misinformation
it's a vicious cycle
and it is almost entirely
a uniquely american cycle
we have to take another quick break i am
fair and cousins find me on twitter
instagram and facebook at farren cousins
i'm in for david pakman this is the
david pakman show and we'll be right
back
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts you can support the
show for as little as two dollars a
month check it out at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow welcome back to the
david pakman show i am fair and cousins
sitting in for david pakman and hey if
you like what you've heard from me these
last two days you can follow me on my
two youtube channels youtube.com slash
the ring of fire i'm also youtube.com
farronbalanced and twitter facebook
instagram and if you're so inclined
tiktok i'm at
fahren balanced
we've still got a lot to cover and not a
whole lot of show left folks so let's
get right back into it we've got a new
poll this week that i think
tells us more than what the pollsters
thought it was telling us
and it is this
for the first time this year the number
one issue on the minds of american
voters as we head into the midterms is
not
the economy it's not inflation it's not
anything
having to do with their personal
finances
the number one issue
or i should say the most popular issue
for american voters because it's only at
14 percent but everything is lower than
that or sorry 21 but everything else is
lower than that
is
threats
to democracy
21 a plurality of voters
say the number one issue they have on
their minds right now heading into the
midterms
are the growing
threats
to democracy
it's not surprising is it
because what i think this really tells
us is
the january 6 hearings
have worked
that's why threats to democracy
is at the forefront of everybody's
brains right now because we are watching
the threats to democracy or at least we
were over the summer unfold on tv those
hearings by the way are going to resume
once again in september which is
wonderful we need them to
you know we kind of had like the the
season finale in the summer now we're
ready for season two
because they left us a lot of
cliffhangers that we need resolved
before the midterms and if republicans
take back over we kind of have to get on
that quick because they're going to kill
the committee and several of the members
will no longer be in congress liz cheney
and adam kinzinger obviously
but 21
isn't a huge percentage right because
you still have other ones um
16 percent chose cost of living
as the you know second most important 14
said jobs in the economy
57 percent by the way say the
investigation into former president
donald trump should continue so
when we see these numbers that say 21
percent say the threats to democracy are
number one please understand a majority
of people are directly referring to
donald frickin trump
it's not like we're dealing with trump
supporters who think oh the threat to
democracy of the fbi barging in on the
former president and making him cry
nope
these are people who look at donald
trump
they look at january 6th they look at
all the investigations and you know
criminal allegations out there and they
say you know what
that's that that's very concerning to me
and
furthermore
knowing now that this has emerged as the
biggest issue for american voters
it also helps explain why we've seen the
shifts in these polls in just the last
couple weeks
right
ever since biden was sworn in as
president all the polls already showed
us republicans are going to sweep the
2022 midterms
and it's not just the polls that were
telling us that history tells us that
typically
when a new president takes power if the
party also controls congress they will
lose control of congress in the first
midterms following their you know first
year in office
that's historically what happens it's
only not happened a handful of times
so historically it was supposed to
happen the polls were showing it was
totally going to happen and now the
polls are showing that oops generic
democrat beats generic republican
so sometimes we have to take all of this
polling data
you know like for example this stuff
says well a majority of voters say the
threat to democracy is number one
these polls show democrats are now
possibly going to win the midterms
but
but you have to finish the work you have
to put the polls together
you know my degree is in political
science and that is literally
one of the things that they teach you in
the political polling classes is how to
take the data from all the different
polls
and put it all together
to extrapolate what it actually means
and unfortunately i see too few
individuals out there doing that
you can't just report on hey here's a
new poll blah blah see you later no you
have to tie it in and make it relevant
to everything
and that's what too few groups are not
doing because that's not mentioned in
this story
it should be
but it's not
so
brush up on your poli sci folks because
that's how you read polls you don't read
them individually you read them as a
part of something bigger
and hey
speaking of people who didn't do well in
polls
madison calhoun has been back in the
news uh pretty much for about a week or
so now
because the guy just can't stop having
problems
with his campaign finances
and i know that seems weird right
because the guy lost his primary
obviously he's not running for office
anymore he's he's a lame duck he's going
to be leaving at the end of the year
but
last week it was revealed
that madison cawthorne
is a month late
in filing his most recent campaign
finance disclosures
we also know
that in those disclosures that are still
waiting to be filed he's got thousands
of dollars that he's spent at
chick-fil-a thousands of dollars that he
spent at cigar shops
and uh what's some of the other 21 000
for lodging in florida three thousand
dollars at a place called papa's beer
and of course thousands uh hundreds of
thousands of dollars in consulting fees
that he's paid out to his consultants
who clearly did not do a very good job
for him
but he's a month late
hadn't filed it
and now according to a new report from
the daily beast
we know why
because as it turns out according to
this new report madison cawthorne is out
of money
the people working for his campaign said
it was basically dollar in dollar out
guy raised millions but he spent even
more than that
now you may not think that's a problem
right haha you ran out of money you're
not going to be re-elected anyway so you
suck
it's a little bit murkier than that
though folks
you see there's a law believe it or not
we actually do still have a couple
campaign finance laws out there and one
of them
says that you can raise money for both
your primary race and the general
election race at the same time
good however
you cannot touch
that general election money
until you've won your primary and if you
don't win your primary
you have to pay all that money back to
the donors who gave it to you
the general election fund
doesn't matter what happens with your
primary money if you lose you lose
whatever but if you've raised money for
a general election and you lose your
primary all of the general election
money by law
has to go back to the people that gave
it to you and that makes sense right
that's actually protecting the donors
which explains why we have that law
because it protects the wealthy
corporations pouring money in
madison cawthorne as i said is out of
money
and he had a lot of money in his general
election fund
so
put two and two together and you realize
that madison cawthorne can't afford to
pay back all the money that he is
supposed to be paying back and that is
according to the people who worked with
his campaign that spoke to the daily
beast
so madison calhoun's in a lot of trouble
here
he's going to have to come up possibly
with millions of dollars to return to
his donors
and that likely
again we can't say for certain but it is
likely
why he hasn't gone ahead and filed his
campaign finance disclosures because it
would show that he spent all the money
that he's legally not allowed to spend
so in addition to no longer being in
congress
he may no longer be a free man if he
continues to uh spend money so
frivolously that he's legally not
allowed to touch
if he does have any money left over
i'd say it's time to spend that on a
good lawyer
and finally today again folks i'm so
sorry we are running out of time but i
do have one more thing i want to talk
about here and that is south dakota
governor christie gnome
christie gnome
an ethics board this week in south
dakota
said that it's likely
likely they said
that she engaged in misconduct
with regard to her daughter's real
estate appraiser's license
this is a weird weird story
because it also involves a republican
attorney general who had to uh resign in
disgrace
after he ran over somebody
but this republican attorney general at
one point was hot on gnomes trail
working on this case you know and
tilly pretty much killed somebody and
had to leave office it's not funny that
somebody died it's just funny that these
republicans in south dakota are so
screwed up
but anyway
what had happened was that christy
gnome's daughter a couple years ago uh
was at cassidy peters
who wanted to become a real estate
appraiser
but you gotta have a license in south
dakota to do that
so she applies she takes the tests all
of this and they look at it and they say
nah you can't have your real estate
appraiser's license
but mommy was the governor
so
what christy gnome did was she called a
meeting
and she called a meeting
with the state employee who ran the
agency that gives those licenses the
woman's direct supervisor and the state
labor secretary
and for some reason even though she's
not a part of the government cassidy
peters
gnome's daughter was also involved in
that meeting
four months after that meeting magically
christine's daughter
gets that real estate license or real
estate appraiser's license
and then they also fired
the individual
who had originally denied her the
license
we do not know
i mean
we don't know for certain
what happened in that meeting we
obviously see the outcomes the person
who denied the license loses her job
they then pay her 200 thousand dollars
to not file a discrimination suit
against them and
cassidy peters gets her real estate
appraisers license everybody goes home
happy right
and so this ethics board in south dakota
says we think you know it's likely
that she engaged in misconduct likely
the issue is not over but unfortunately
we are out of time but i think i got a
lot that we know so far but anyway thank
you so much for tuning in we got a great
bonus show coming up for everybody
including rick scott leaving the country
right as republicans want answers about
where all their money went i am farron
cousins i've been in for david pakman
you can find me at youtube.com the ring
of fire youtube
dot com slash fair and balanced twitter
facebook instagram fair and balanced
this is the david pakman show
thanks for watching